and you might think well so what what
does that let us
do well the short answer is a surprising
amount so
i'd love you to you i asked you to prime
up your computer before can you open it
up
i'm going to show you one of the things
we can do now that we have established
uh what we call the identity of complex
numbers what makes two
complex numbers identical to each other
are the real components the same
are the imaginary components the same
on your computer what i'd like you to go
to is and i've picked a question
in exercise 1a it's 10b 10b yeah
question 10
b which i didn't assign to you before so
we're going to do it together
10b have a read of question 10 look at
what it's asking you to do
and then we'll have a look at b together
just take a moment to read it
do you have it there can you see it
right so question 10 for
abcd however many questions there are it
says
read that phrase there right at the top
the preface of the question right it
says
by by what by equating
the real and imaginary components
pause it's talking about these things
right by equating the real
and the imaginary components of this
equation right
they want us to find out what the
unknowns are in this case they're
calling x and y
rather than a and b you'll see them just
as frequently okay
by equating the real parts and the
imaginary parts work out what x and y
are so what's going on here right
if you have a look at this and you can
go ahead right now we're going to do
this together if you have a look at this
equation we're saying this thing is a
complex number
over here once i expand and simplify
this mess will also be a complex number
if i'm saying that they're equal to each
other that means the real components
have to be separately equal
and the imaginary components have to be
separately equal does that make sense
let's have a go okay so we're going to
expand this guy out it's mercifully
simple that's why i chose this example
so
we're going to start with one lot of
that second pair of brackets
plus help me expand the next part what
are we going to get here
4 4 i
x plus
four i squared y i'm pretty happy with
that
um you're going to get to the point
where you're comfortable enough to just
go to negative one in your brain after
you do this a lot like you can do it
hundreds and thousands of times but i
encourage you especially on the first
line
write i squared anyway it's a good sort
of error checking thing for yourself
so that's that's the entire left hand
side okay with that and then on the
right hand side nothing
has changed you just have 6 plus 7 i
now we have tiding up to do on the left
hand side right and what i would
encourage you to do
remember i said to you colors are gonna
be very useful to you i like to
highlight
the parts that i'm going to collect
together before i start to do that
collection
so in the middle i've got these two bits
that are going to become the imaginary
component
and then i also have these two bits
that are going to become the real
component and i'm going to write that in
such a way as to highlight that
so we said this i squared is going to be
negative 1. so at the front here and i'm
going to
even though it's kind of unnecessary but
it's helping my brain right
i'm going to put the real component in
brackets what's in the real component
what's the first thing that's the easy
one it's just x right no change
then the other bit is going to be minus
4 y
minus 4 y there is the real component in
fact
i will highlight it for us just by even
writing
this is the real component of the
left-hand side
over here okay and then just like
i have been here right i'm trying to
highlight the fact that there's an
imaginary component over here
so i'm going to say plus i and then here
comes
the b right here comes the b so what do
i put
into here have a think i'm factoring out
i right
y yep that that y is hanging out there i
took out that factor of i and then
and then in here i take out the i and i
get 4x so i'm pretty happy with that
right and again nothing has happened on
my right hand side so
this thing here is the imaginary
component
of the left hand side okay but now i'm
going to bring in what they suggested to
us
in the question i'm going to equate the
real part here
with this real part here does that make
sense like there's nowhere else for this
six to come from
it has to come from these terms and
likewise there's nowhere else for
seven to come from than from these terms
so in fact
what i then form and we should write
what we're doing we should say
equating the real
and imaginary components
i'm actually going to get a pair of
equations one that looks like this and
one looks like this but i'm going to
fill in the numbers yeah
so i'm going to get here's the real part
x minus 4y
on the left hand side is going to equal
look at the right
it's 6 right there's an equation and
then i have
i'm going to write it in x's and y
orders because that's how i usually do
things
4x plus y equals
7. it's the imaginary part over here and
the imaginary part over there are
you okay with that so i've just drawn
right written out the specific version
of this
for this question so from the original
equation i'm like
oh my my equations are sprouting right i
have two equations here um
but i have to solve them together what
do we call that when you're solving two
equations or more together
simultaneous equations so i'm going to
pause for a minute because i think you
can handle this
we've turned a weirdo looking problem
with complex stuff
into a much more familiar looking
problem that's all just real numbers we
know how to do this
so i'm going to suggest you maybe name
these equations
and then see if you can come up for some
values of x
and y call corners over if you need a
hand or you think you've got
an answer um if you're thinking an
answer real fast go ahead and
substitute it back in that's how we
check whether equations solutions are
valid for an equation
give that a go and we'll see how you
fare
did you get some values for x and y yep
okay
from memory i think you're getting an x
of two
and a y of negative one okay you're
happy with that and of course for those
of you who got there real fast
i hope you did come up to this first
line the one we started with
take this left hand side and then you're
multiplying 1 plus 4i by
2 minus i and if you if you've
got it right okay you will expand out to
6 plus 7i
really minor note before we move further
because you have this situation with
simultaneous equations that guess what
gonna happen a lot right you're gonna
try and find a real component you're
gonna find
an imaginary component because you're
solving for two variables
you generally need two equations which
is generalizable by the way if you had
like
15 variables you were solving for
because you had a death wish you need 15
equations to also
solve it that's how systems of linear
equations work
anyway one quick note just because i was
looking around at some of the working
that you did was
you fairly quickly realized you're like
oh this is back to stage five
stuff like i've solved scientists
equations before you've got two methods
or two strategies generally your
disposal what are they by the way
substitution and elimination did most of
you go for elimination
or do mostly go for substitution who
went for substitution hands up i'm just
curious
and elimination wow really evenly spit
okay that's that's fine with me
i suppose it was easy enough like you
could take
you could add 4y to both sides you'd
have x as the subject maybe or you did
it something similar to here
the only note i want to make because i
noticed this as i was going around
whatever you did you're going to change
either one or two in some way
to then allow them to interact with each
other for instance if you went by
elimination which half of you did
you might have gone with this equation
here and multiplied it by
four yeah that'd be a reasonable way to
do it you get this
and what you're doing is you're setting
up to add this equation
with the first one and then your y's
cancel off you go okay now the thing
that i noticed a lot of people doing i'm
not writing it because
i'm going to encourage you not to i've
noticed several people calling this
equation three
now that's that's not wrong i mean it's
the third equation okay
i'm going to encourage you to do
something slightly different
i'm going to encourage you to name this
third equation in some way that helps
you know where the equation came from
okay this is 2a because it came from two
the reason this is just like a handy
extra thing to do like you won't get
into any problems if you call this
equation three
but i've seen students especially when
they are you know under pressure
running out of time in an exam they're
like here's equation three
and they substitute it into the wrong
equation like they might take equation
three and put it into two
can you see why it's a bad idea when you
sub an equation into itself
you end up with something trivial like
one equals one or zero equals zero and
you're like great but
but like like no that's that's not a
good thing that's not helpful to me
right
because substituting an equation into
itself doesn't give you any extra
information
you've got to substitute into something
different make sense especially when
you're going to get more equations
flying around this is going to be very
helpful okay
so we got our values of x
and y and then you can pop them in happy
one more piece of
formal language notation we need to
introduce before we go any further and
some of you
noticed this earlier than i intended
because i accidentally assigned a few
wrong questions
we've been talking about multiplication
by complex conjugates remember that
right so in the case of this
general complex number our complex
conjugate would be
a minus ib okay
so this ends up being really useful for
simplifying stuff out
so because we talk about this guy a heck
of a what it gets its own form of
notation right anything you use a lot
it's like we should
put a symbol on that so because it comes
from this in the same way that you name
it in reference to where it came from
we call this guy z bar we put a
horizontal line over the top and some of
you might have noticed this in
the exercise so this is our notation for
indicating a
complex conjugate
[Applause]
and as you read it out i'd say like this
is z this is z bar you might
find w bar or or z one bar or something
like that okay
so what they mean is this